[Music]
Hello, good afternoon and welcome to I'd
like to know. My name is CA Murray and
it is my privilege and pleasure to
welcome you to what we see as a very fun
program as part of our Sum TV lineup. We
get to answer your questions. We get to
hear from you and uh by the grace of God
go into the word of God and answer your
questions. Um I am in the presence of
Pastor Daniel Daniel Miranda. He is our
our guest for the afternoon and perhaps
uh Lord willing we'll see more of your
face uh in the next little bit. That is
our prayer. That is our hope. Pastor
Boore is doing something that I don't
like to do. He's at the dentist right
now. And uh I'm sure he doesn't want to
be there either. He'd much rather be
here, but he's at the dentist. And um
pastor was here and so we pressed him
into service. And we thank you pastor
for being with us.
Thank you, Pastor Murray. And it's a
pleasure for me to be in this program
and we hope that we can answer your
questions and study the Bible. We we
make you this promise as we always do.
We promise to give you answers from the
word of God. We're a little late in
earth's history to be getting the
thoughts of the mind of men. What you
want is a word from the Lord. Amen. So
if a word can be found in the word,
we're going to find it and give it to
you in answer to your questions. Should
you should you like to participate in
our uh question and answer period, we
have uh an address that you can write
your questions to. Send them to
tvsumtv.org.
That's tvsumtv.org
and we will get to your questions as
soon as we can. You will find that we we
Daniel, we don't get to a lot of
questions each day because uh we kind of
we kind of get into the questions and
kind of stay there. So, we're not going
for speed. We're going uh to try to be
thorough. We're going to try to answer
your questions as completely as
possible. So, that sometimes negates
speed. It's not the number of questions
that we answer, it's the depths of the
questions. And we certainly want you to
feel that your question has been
respected and addressed. And we're going
to try to do that. Daniel, if you will,
and I'm gonna call you Daniel, I could
call you Pastor Miranda, but I will call
you Daniel.
Daniel's fine.
And and call me CA, please.
Okay.
If you say Pastor Murray, I may not
answer you because I I don't hear that
that often. Okay.
Would you open our our program in
prayer, please?
Sure. Let's pray.
Dear heavenly father, we recognize that
only through the power and the wisdom of
your Holy Spirit, we can understand your
word. We do not have the wisdom to
answer these questions, but you do. So
we pray that as we uh delve into these
questions that you may give us the
wisdom and the right words to find the
answers from your word. In the name of
Jesus we pray. Amen.
Amen. Amen. Daniel is a young, handsome,
good-looking guy. He would make a great
addition to his staff. His wife is in
the studio with us taking pictures on
the phone. She's there uh behind the
camera. And uh they are wonderful
couple. So it's good to have you here,
man.
Thank you. Thank you.
Uh we we we did the same trick. I say
trick that pastor Bor and I always do.
We we don't study together, you know, we
don't get together in a room and and
sync up our answers. We just study the
word of God. And usually we come out
with the same text
and we come out with the basically the
same answers even though we haven't
studied together. And we think that's
the spirit of God working uh in our
behalf. So we're going to pull out this
first one. Uh Daniel, it's from Peter.
He asks, "If Jesus is our high priest
and he has to purify the sanctuary in
heaven, my question is, are there sins
in the sanctuary as it was in the
earthly sanctuary?"
Well, that's a good question. Um
so the the question of the sanctuary
it's
um the sanctuary
we as Adventist people we understand
that the sanctuary helped us unlock many
things
and part of that was based on the
earthly service of the century. So
the Bible says in Hebrews and I would
like to quote from Hebrews chapter 9 23
and 24
um that the earthly service of the
sanctuary was a shadow of the heavenly
uh and we'll
uh begin there in Hebrews uh chapter 9.
We're going to read verses 23 and 24. Uh
what Paul tells us here
um it was therefore necessary that the
patterns of things in the heavens should
be purified with this that the heavenly
things themselves with better sacrifices
than this.
For Christ is not enter into the holy
places were made with hands which are
the figure or the shadows of the true
but into heaven itself now to appear in
the presence of God for us. So the fact
that the sanctuary needs to be cleansed
that tells us that the sanctuary is
defiled. Now that signs that sounds
contradictory because we think of heaven
a pure and holy place.
Uh but then there is something defiled
in heaven. Now what defiles the
sanctuary? The sins as we see it in the
earthly service. The sins defile the
sanctuary. Therefore, it is necessary
that the sanctuary be cleansed as the
earthly sanctuary needed to be cleansed.
Yes,
the earthly sanctuary was cleansed by
the blood of bulocks and and lambs and
and um rams. But the heavenly sanctuary
is cleansed with the better sacrifice
with the blood of Jesus Christ. Now,
where where are the s where are these
sins recorded? They are in the books.
Yes. Mhm. As in the earthly century,
they were recorded in the horns of the
altar. In the heavenly century, uh there
is a book, the book of record of sin,
the sins are there.
Mhm.
Well said. You know, when when when I
saw this question, uh the first text
that came to my mind was Daniel 8:14.
Sure.
Uh and and for several reasons. One,
because it answers the question. Uh,
two, because when I was taking Daniel
and Revelation in school, I was carrying
a an A throughout the whole quarter
and I missed one question on the final
exam. Uh, Daniel 8:14.
The question is about the 2300 days and
I I put Daniel 8:16 or my brain just
wasn't working and my my teacher gave me
a B.
One question on the final exam. I mean,
he took my A down to a B and that has
stayed with me. I've been out of school
many many years, but I haven't forgotten
that.
Uh, so let's let's go to that. Daniel
8:14. Uh uh I I praise Dr. Bill because
he he made me a better student of the
word. But the Bible says in Daniel 8:14
uh and he said to me, "For 2,300 days,
then the sanctuary shall be cleansed."
Now, of course, that is the longest time
prophecy in the Bible.
Yeah.
But it also says many things. Uh the
sanctuary is going to be cleansed.
That's because there's something in
there making it dirty or defiling it.
Exactly. So the the heavenly sanctuary
can indeed uh be cleansed because sins
are credited to that sanctuary and they
must be cleansed. Uh and that process
began in 1844. Any good student of the
word who was Adventist knows that uh the
Millerites are our forefathers uh sort
of cut their teeth on that particular
text. Uh we studied it, we restudied it,
we we knew something very very important
was happening in uh 1844. And of course
it was the beginning of Christ's
ministry, his uh antitical ministry, the
cleansing of the sanctuary. So yes, um
it it uh there is a cleansing because
there is sin defiling the sanctuary even
as we speak.
Yeah.
Yeah. Absolutely. Um and I think of uh
Ro He Hebrews chapter 8 also verses uh
uh 1-3
uh where it says that um now of the
things which we have spoken this is the
sum we have such an high priest who is
set on the right hand of the throne of
the majesty in the heavens the ministry
of the sanctuary and of the true
tabernacle which the Lord pitched and
not man for every high priest is
ordained to offer gifts and sacrifices.
Wherefore it is of necessity that this
man have somewhat also to offer for if
he were on earth he should not be a
priest.
Mhm.
Then verse 5 says who serve unto the
example and shadow of heavenly things.
So um as you mentioned Daniel 8:14
uh there is a sanctuary and we
understand this is the sanctuary in
heaven. Yes, the heavenly sanctuary
because in 1844
there was no earthly sanctuary. Mhm.
So we see here the sanctuary in heaven
that needs to be cleansed. Cleansed from
what? As you said, and as the Bible
says, cleansed from sin. Uh the problem
of sin was not resolved in the
courtyard.
Yes.
Uh it actually was resolved during the
day of atonement.
Amen.
So we need a day of atonement. Yes. To
resolve the problem of sin.
Yes. And we are in that day even now.
You know, as you well know, Daniel, when
the the children of Israel went to to
the the temple, to the sanctuary,
they're also going to school. You know,
they you're dealing with the people who
didn't have typewriters, didn't have
computers, didn't have iPads, didn't
have iPhones, uh could barely read or
write. So, the services, the sacrifices,
the colors, the cloths, the material,
all of these things were teaching them
lessons about what was happening in
heaven. And of course, the Lord was very
very exacting with Moses as to the the
the height, the length, the shape, the
width, uh the material, the wood. All of
these things had special meaning to the
people of God so that they could
understand precisely what was going on
in in heaven.
Yeah.
And actually those that's good news for
good news for us. Uh we better have our
sins
in heaven so that they might be in in
the finally cleansed.
Yes. Yes. Because the sins that are not
in heaven, those are the sins that will
not be cleansed.
Yeah. Those the ones you got to pay for.
Exactly. That's exactly.
So, it's it's a very good question. Uh
because you when you think of heaven,
you think of a pure place. You don't
think of sins and defiling things, but
indeed they are there, but they will one
day be taken care of and heaven will be
clean and beautiful once again. Well
done, Daniel. Good question. Very good
question. Um we have one that is coming
from this is an interesting name. uh
titta teta t- a h
um and it's asking Lucifer is created by
God. God created everything. How come he
didn't prevent sin from coming into this
world?
Now I've got an answer for that but I
I'll let I'll let you start if you want.
Sure. Sure.
So I would rephrase the question because
the question says how come didn't God
prevent sin from coming into this into
this world? This sounds as if God was
responsible for the entering of sin into
the universe,
but we understand that God was not
responsible for that.
Lucifer, as Ezekiel 28 tells us, Lucifer
was created perfect. Yes. I mean, God
didn't create the devil.
He created Lucifer, a perfect being.
Yes.
Uh
he perverted himself. Uh he allowed
pride to come into his heart, vanity,
and selfishness, jealousy. We we see we
understand all that situation. But all
all this boils down into the principle
of love.
Yes.
I mean God doesn't exact love from his
created beings. God wants the free
expression of love. So when God created
uh the universe, when God created the
heavenly beings, um God created them
with free will.
Yes. And that's a that was a risk since
the beginning because that would um
allow or give room to any of these
beings to maybe revel
in the future. Now what did God or what
does God use in order to keep the
harmony of his government or of his
kingdom? Love. Like the argument that he
uses is love. In other words, he wants
his beings to serve him out of love. But
this being Lucifer, he decided not to
follow that principle. He decided to
love himself above God. And God had a
plan
before even before sin entered into the
world, which was which was the plan of
salvation.
Yes.
So, uh maybe I know CA you have
something else to add, but I'll I'll
close with this. And
God uh could have just simply not
created Lucifer or God could have just
simply destroyed him when he sinned. But
that wouldn't have uh resolved the
problem for several reasons. Number one,
um he would not have allowed the
principles of sin to develop.
Yes.
In other words, and and in this way, the
the heavenly beings would understand why
God did that. Secondly, uh the heavenly
beings would obey him out of fear.
Correct.
Okay. Then this is a god that whoever
doesn't obey him then he just kills him.
So God allowed Satan to mature his
thoughts and his principles so that the
entire universe
Yes.
could be convinced that the way of
unrighteousness is the way of death.
I like your answer Daniel and and I
co-sign it very very much. We look at a
very familiar text. First John 4:8. He
that loveth not knoweth not God for God
is love. If God is love, then love could
do no other.
You know, um you could almost say love
got God into this fix,
but love will get him through it and get
him out of it. Um he loved so much that
he gave his only begotten son. So, he
had the answer to the problem. The sin
issue didn't catch God by surprise.
Exactly.
He he knew what was coming. And I think
the thing that sometimes we humans
forget, Daniel, is the fact that we are
suffering because of sin, but so is God.
Yeah.
And God is suffering even more than we
are.
So he opened himself up for uh this
suffering. Knew it was coming, but chose
to do it anyway because that's how love
functions.
Love doesn't get truncated or cut short
or or cut off because trouble is going
to come. Now, when you uh started dating
your lovely wife, Kelly
Mhm.
once you tell her, "I love you," you've
given her a number of things. One of the
things you give her is the ability to
hurt you.
Yeah.
Yeah. And and and how much you love
determines how much control she has over
that. If you don't love her much, well,
if she walks away, I don't love her
anyway. But if you really love her
and she turns her back on you, then it
hurts a lot.
Well, God is is love. Mhm.
So this sin issue that we as humans are
going through hurts him a lot because he
he's he's perfect love. He's he's the
the the the epitome of love. Yeah. So
when we turn our back on him, when we
walk away from him, he's suffering much
more than we are. So we almost ought to
be I say it this way, kind of sad for
God because he's suffering. He's been
suffering through this thing for 7,000
years. uh we get three score and 10 and
and and we're you know sucking our
teeth, but God's been suffering much
more. Um so um he it's like when you if
you have children,
you don't know if those children are
going to be good or bad,
obedient or disobedient, but you have
them anyway because you love your wife
and out of that love children come.
That's natural. You pray to God that
things will work out well, but you have
no guarantee. But that does not stop you
from taking the risk.
You do it. You know, you may have
wonderful children. They may all be
pastors. They may all be doctors. They
may all be lawyers. Or they all may all
be drug addicts. You don't know.
But you do it because you love. And when
you love, love creates. Love holds on.
And that's what what God is involved in
right now. Even as we
Exactly. I I like CA what you said that
loving is taking a risk.
Yeah. Because God could have just chosen
to just be the Godhead by themselves
alone in the universe without creating
any any other being.
Precisely.
Just to prevent sin from coming into the
world. But that wouldn't be love because
love, as you said, love creates.
Yes.
Love tries to extend that love to other
creatures.
Um, so I think the principle of love
helps us helps us understand this issue
of sin into the world.
Very much so. Very much so. You know,
when when you were younger, we all had
it. You know, you you you're like a a
little girl and she doesn't like you.
You know, you're crushed, but you
recover. You know, you do and you find
someone else. Well, God doesn't have a
plan B.
Uh God only has plan A. If they turn
their back on me, then uh we see it for
the first time in Genesis 3:15. Uh
Christ is going to come and he's going
to fix it. He's going to sacrifice his
life to fix this because that's the only
way it can be fixed through the death of
of God himself. Uh so God's got the
answer and uh he's got the remedy and
the remedy of course is is Jesus Christ.
That's amazing love.
Yeah, it is amazing love indeed.
Amen.
Good question. Good question. Okay,
let's move. We're moving on through
pretty good. Um,
I've got
Alexander
and he wants an explanation of Romans
chapter 7:es 1-6.
And I think this will probably consume
the rest of the time that we have, but
we'll look at Romans chapter 7. Romans
chapter 7. I am there. And um, we want
to look at verses 1- 6. Uh one of my
favorite texts in the Bible is the next
the next chapter chapter 8 verse one.
Now there therefore no condemnation. So
this is a
this chapter has occasion some you know
some trouble some drama in the lives of
some some people but I I'll read it and
um then we'll sort of weigh out. Okay.
Uh Romans chapter 7 I'm beginning verse
one. I'm in the New King James. Or do
you not know, brethren, for I speak to
those who know the law, that the law has
dominion over a man as long as he lives?
For the woman who has a husband is bound
by the law to her husband as long as he
lives. But if the husband dies, she is
released from the law of her husband. So
then, if while her husband lives, she
marries another man, she will be called
an adulteress. Uh but if her husband
dies, she is free from that law, so that
she is no adulteress, though she has
married another man. Verse four,
therefore, my brethren, you also have
become dead to the law through the body
of Christ, that you may be married to
another, to him who was raised from the
dead, that we should bear fruit to God.
For when we were in the flesh, the
sinful passions which were aroused by
the law were at work in our members to
bear fruit to death. But now I'm in
verse six. We have been delivered from
the law, having died to what we were
held by, so that we should serve sin by
the newness of spirit and not in the
oldness of the letter. He wants verses
1-6. That is 1-6.
What say ye? Well, I recently preached
on this uh chapter, the seventh uh
chapter of Romans. And this is a very
interesting illustration that Paul's
Paul brings out here. Um and this is uh
my my sermon was about spiritual
adultery.
Uhhuh.
And this is what I see in a nutshell
here. Spiritual adultery because we see
here an illustration of a woman who is
married to a husband. So we see the same
woman and let's say that woman is us
that woman is the church. In verse four
it says uh ye also are become dead to
the law by the body of Christ. So um the
woman here is the church let's say or
the individual the believer.
The first husband is the old man
and the second husband
is Christ. So what Paul is trying to say
as I understand it here
is that if a woman that is married let's
say you know my wife is married to me
but if she um goes with another man
while I'm still alive I mean she's bound
by the law by the seventh commandment
to me as long as I live.
Yes.
But if I die she is released from that
law and she's free to marry another man.
uh in the same sense when we are dead uh
in Christ to the law. In other words, we
have accepted Christ we are uh he's
making reference chapter six when we are
buried with him by baptism into into the
death of Christ. So when we are dead uh
uh we then the old man dies so that we
can marry to the new husband uh who is
Christ. Mhm. Mhm. You know, I like that
one of the key things because this
particular chapter has been used by some
to say that we are no longer obligated
to keep the law. And of course, that is
a mislication of what he's saying. If we
look at one of the key words in in the
very first verse is is dominion.
Dominion.
Um dominion
the Greek word is coro or curio. I think
it's coro. uh it means to exercise
lordship or to control
uh the individual's life. So Paul is
saying that what we are dead to is is
the negative aspects of the law as far
as controlling your your future.
Exactly.
Your future is no longer determined by
the law because the wages of sin is
death. Your future now is determined by
your love for and your relationship with
Jesus Christ. So you are you are excused
from you are out from under the
condemnation of the law which he he
brings out very clearly in the next
chapter. You are no longer bound to that
condemnation because you are now in
Christ Jesus. So it's not it has nothing
to do with keeping the law. It's the
condemnation that comes from breaking
the law. Exactly. So now you are in
Christ Jesus. So you've got a brand new
life. The the later on in the same
chapter, the Bible tells me the law is
holy and just and good. So it's not
negative, it's it's positive. But the
the problem comes that I am sinful. And
of course, when I am sinful, the law
judges me and and tells me that I must
die. But when I come out from under the
weight of the law and accept Jesus
Christ, I've got a whole new life.
I'm a whole new person. I've got a a new
husband wife relationship in Christ
Jesus that I didn't have before.
Yeah. Correct. Yeah. So that releases is
from the condemnation of the law, not
from keeping the law itself.
Yes.
Yeah. Because the law still rules
uh our relationship uh with Christ.
Yeah. I I I refer to the text here in uh
Revelation of Revelation Romans 7:12.
Therefore, the law is holy, just and the
commandment holy, just and good. So
something that is holy, just, and good,
God doesn't want to get you out from
doing. He wants you get you to get you
out from the penalty of that of that uh
particular part of the law. It's it's a
very good question because there are
many who are confused about the law and
there are so many who misapply this
Daniel and say that this is trying to
tell us that we've got to we've got to
be uh free from the keeping of the law
and that is not so. Um it is the law
that define of course the Bible says
without the law there is no sin. You you
need the law to define sin for you.
Yeah. So the problem is not the law and
Paul says it here in this chapter. The
problem is sin that dwells in him as he
says.
Uh so the problem is not the law. The
problem is uh uh when we're laid by sin
when we are when we have not died to sin
in Jesus Christ. So we are controlled by
the power of sin in our lives. Yes. So
that's the problem that keeps us like
leads us to break the law over and over.
Precisely. We are born in sin shaped
iniquity. We go through our lives just
living our lives. Then we come to the
Lord and the law tells me this thing
you've been doing all your life is sin.
Yeah.
That's that's not like the Lord. So um
we would not even know that our
activities are sinful without the law
because the parameters of sin are
defined by the law. And uh correct. Then
when we give ourselves to Jesus Christ,
we move over into what I just said is
one of my favorite texts. Uh Romans
chapter 8 verse one. There is therefore
now no condemnation to those who are in
Christ Jesus who do not walk according
to the flesh but according to the spirit
you know so we get a brand new life a
real new life in uh in Christ Jesus and
if we are faithful to him and walk with
him continually he will walk us through
the gates and into the city. You touched
on something that I wanted to just touch
in our last we got two minutes just
about left to go. The fact that the
problem is not the law. The problem is
us. Us.
We are the problem. Walk me through that
what you just said again because I think
it's very very important. I want our
audience to get that.
Yeah. So, uh Paul see Paul uh says in
verse 17 that now then it is no more I
that do it but sin that dwelleth in me.
Yes.
And then in verse 14 it says, "For I
know what that the law is spiritual, but
I am carnal sold under sin."
So the law is not the problem.
No,
he he was he recognizes that he was the
problem.
Yeah.
Yeah. I I think it's it's it's a very
important point. The law is holy, just
and good in verse 12. But I am not.
There's nothing holy, just, and good
about me.
And when I am faced with the law, then I
see myself as I really am. It's a
mirror, you know. It it shows me um
my defects of character
but it doesn't solve them.
No, very true. I can break the mirror. I
can break the glass but my character is
still flawed. The glasses is gone but I
have not changed. It does not solve
them. The the the solving of the problem
of course is
Jesus Christ is Jesus Christ and that's
the only place we get. So you see this
this tension in uh chapter 7 and chapter
8. there is this tension between the
goodness of the law and my own
unworthiness. But when I come to Christ
Jesus through his blood, through his
sanctifying process, uh through the
justification that comes with loving
him, I become worthy and I become the
keeper of the law.
And uh in closing the last few minute,
the last few seconds, uh the the reason
why Paul, the man of Romans 7, struggles
is because he's trying to serve to
masters.
Yes. Yes.
And that's the problem. Mhm.
Because uh he's trying to join the the
the new husband, the second husband
without dying to the first.
Without dying to the first
then you are another time. I hope that
uh this time together has been uh
edifying to you and spiritually
uplifting. We we have a good time on
this program and uh we love to study the
word of God together. Join us next time.
I'd like to know. We'll be here. You'll
be there. And God bless.
[Music]